>> Tucker: A LOT OF
ENTERTAINERS ARE VERY QUIET
ABOUT THEIR POLITICAL VIEWS.
BOB RITCHIE, KID ROCK IS NOT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING, ACCORDING TO
HIM, HIS VIEWS ARE NOT UNCOMMON
IN THE MUSIC INDUSTRY, THEY ARE
JUST A PRESS BUT WE HIM BECAUSE
EASE DOWN LIKE HE IS A FREQUENT
GOLF PARTNER OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM WHAT HE
THINKS OF HIM, AND ABOVE ALL,
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF TONY FAUCI?
HERE IS MORE OF OUR EXTENDED
INTERVIEW WITH KID ROCK.
HOW DID YOU MEET TRUMP?
>> AT THE WHITE HOUSE!
WITH SARAH PALIN.
SARAH PALIN ASKED MY EARLY RIGHT
WHEN HE GOT ELECTED, HE INVITED
HER TO DINNER TO BRING SOME
INTERESTING PEOPLE.
SHE SAYS SHE CALLED ME AND HAD
TO COMMIT TED NUGENT, AND WE
WERE LIKE, HELL YEAH!
GO UP THERE, SPEND A LOT OF
TIMES ON THE GOLF COURSE NOW.
REALLY WEIRD TO GET PHONE CALLS
FROM HIM AND STUFF.
IT'S KIND OF MIND-BLOWING.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S HE LIKE?
>> AWESOME.
SO MUCH FUN.
>> Tucker: WHY?
>> HE KNOWS HOW TO HAVE FUN.
DOESN'T TAKE IT TOO SERIOUSLY.
ENGAGING, JUST OPENING UP WITH
POLITICS BUT I WAS THERE WITH
THE END OF THE CALIPHATE, HE
WANTED TO PUT OUT A TWEET AND IT
WAS LIKE...
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK OUT OF
SCHOOL AND I HOPE I'M NOT.
I'M LIKE, TELL HIM, BUT A WAS
LIKE, HE WAS PARAPHRASING, IF HE
EVER JOINED A CALIPHATE TRYING
TO DO THIS, HE WOULD GET BEAT TO
DEATH.
I SAY, AWESOME!
TWEET THAT OUT.
I CAN'T ADD ANYTHING BETTER THAN
THAT.
IT COMES OUT, IT'S REWARDED AND
MORE POLITICAL WE
REWARDED AND MOREPOLITICALLY CO.
WE WERE LIKE...
[BLEEP].
I MAKE THERE TO RECORD
SOMETIMES!
>> Tucker: YOU DIDN'T THINK
YOU'D HAVE A HAND?
>> "WHAT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
DO ABOUT NORTH KOREA?"
I DON'T THINK I'M QUALIFIED
TO...
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: YOU ARE STILL
PLAYING GOLF WITH THEM DOWN IN
FLORIDA?
HOW'S HE SEEMED?
>> HE SEEMS GREAT.
HE SEEMS GREAT.
AFTER THE ELECTION, HE WAS...
YOU KNOW, A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THERE.
BUT HE'S STILL THE SAME GUY.
HE SITS DOWN AND JUST CUTS IT
UP.
YOU START CUTTING IT UP.
HOW SHARP HE IS, IT'S
INCREDIBLE.
YOU CAN SEE HOW YOU WATCH A
JOE BIDEN INTERVIEW AND THE
TRUMP INTERVIEW.
THERE IS NO COMPARISON.
AND YEAH, TRUMP, HE SPEAKS OFF
THE CUFF.
SOMETIMES YOU GET IT WRONG.
BUT I'D WAY HEAR SOMEONE GET IT
WRONG ONCE IN A WHILE, AT SOME
LEVEL EVERYTHING WAS SCRIPTED.
I'VE STOOD NEXT TO HIM IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE PREPARED
NOTES AND WATCH AND READ ONE
SENTENCE AND LIKE, LET'S GO.
IT'S LIKE, THIS IS AWESOME.
>> KID ROCK, GREAT FRIEND.
DO YOU LIKE AS LEGISLATION OR
YOU HATE IT?
>> I LIKE IT.
>> WE BEEN FIGHTING FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> I'D LIKE THEM FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I SAID HE WAS MY GUY BEFORE HE
GOT THE NOMINATION IN
"ROLLING STONE."
THAT DATES TO NOW, [BLEEP]
COMING AT YOU FROM EVERY ANGLE!
>> IF YOU HAD A MANAGER WHO WAS
IN CONTROL OF YOUR CAREER, HE'D
SAY IT, MAY BE LET'S NOT ON
THIS.
>> I'D GIVE MY OLD MANAGER A
PUNCH.
TOLD ME FLAT OUT WHEN HE STARTED
TO MANAGE MAKE HIM JUST WHAT YOU
KNOW, EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE TO
THIS POINT IN YOUR CAREER TO GET
WHERE YOU'RE AT, I WOULD'VE TOLD
YOU KNOW.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU?
>> GO WITH MY HEART.
JUST GOING BY MY HEART BY THE
SEAT OF MY PANTS, TRYING TO BE A
GOOD PERSON.
BE EDUCATED IF I'M GOING TO
SPEAK ON SOME THINGS BUT
SOMETIMES NOT SO MUCH.
WHATEVER.
JUST CALL IT LIKE I SEE IT.
>> Tucker: WE HAD DINNER AND
YOU ROLLED UP IN A ROLLS-ROYCE,
THE "LET'S GO BRANDON" EDITION?
FOR OUR VIEWERS WHO MIGHT WANT
THE ROLLS-ROYCE "LET'S GO
BRANDON" EDITION, WHERE CAN YOU
GET ONE?
>> YOU GO ONTO THIS THING CALLED
GOOGLE AND YOU TYPE IN "CAR
BADGES, LET'S GO BRANDON."
THERE ARE COMPANIES WITH MY
TRUCK, WHITE BOY EDITION -- BUT
IT LOOKS OFFICIAL!
I WOULD NEVER DRIVE -- I USED TO
SAY TO MYSELF, I'M SO PROUD FOR
HOW HARD I WORK AND WHAT I
CHARGE PEOPLE FOR SHOWS IS WHAT
I THINK IS FAIR.
I CAN HOLD MY
HAD TO HIDE BECAUSE I CAN FEEL
LIKE I NEVER MADE AN NOT HONEST
DOLLAR OFF SOMEONE'S BACK.
I HAD THIS LICENSE PLATE THAT I
HAD FOREVER.
AND I'M LIKE...
I NEED A CAR TO PUT THAT THING
ON.
I NEED TO GET THAT ROLLS-ROYCE.
AND THE "LET'S GO BRANDON" BADGE
CAME OUT AND IT'S LIKE, THERE IS
A HEAVEN.
THIS IS TOO GOOD.
THIS IS TOO MUCH FUN!
>> WITHOUT NAMING NAMES, ARE
THERE OTHER PEOPLE IN YOUR
BUSINESS TO AGREE WITH YOU
PRIVATELY?
>> YES.
IT WAS FUNNY, DURING THE LAST
ELECTION, SOME PEOPLE ON HIS
SIDE, THEY DON'T NAME OF
HOLLYWOOD PEOPLE.
THEY KEPT GOING LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THEY ARE VERY IN THE CLOSET.
IT'S LIKE, THOSE PEOPLE ARE ALL
GAY, THAT'S NUTS?
NO, THEY ARE CLOSET TRUMP FANS!
THAT WAS KIND OF MIND-BLOWING.
I'M NOT GOING TO TALK OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT
TO BE IN THE OPEN FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEY HAVE.
BUT YEAH, THERE'S A TON OF THEM.
ME AND TRUMP TALK ABOUT THAT A
LOT.
"THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY OF
US THERE ARE.
THE VOCAL ONES, SURE.
BUT THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY
OF THEM ARE OUT THERE.
ARE EITHER TRUMP FANS WHO ARE
MORE CONSERVATIVE.
I DON'T KNOW, WHEN I WAS YOUNG,
CONSERVATIVE WAS...
SWEATERS, COLLARED SHIRTS -- OH.
>> Tucker: I HAVEN'T UPDATED
MY LOOKS SINCE THE '80s!
>> IF I SAID THE F WORD IN THE
HOUSE, I WAS RAN OUT THE HOUSE
BECAUSE I WAS PADDLED OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
NOWADAYS, CONSERVATIVES ARE A
LITTLE HIPPER, OUT IN THE OPEN.
I'M SURE THAT'LL BE THE HEADLINE
FROM THE LEFT WING -- I CAN
ALREADY SEE THEIR HEADLINES IN
THIS INTERVIEW.
"TUCKER AND KID ROCK'S LOVE
STORY TOGETHER."
>> Tucker: I'M NOT
EMBARRASSED!
I'M A FAN.
I RESPECT ANYBODY WHO THINKS FOR
THEMSELVES.
WHAT I DON'T LIKE IS PEOPLE WHO
JUST SIGNED UP FOR THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE SOMEONE IN POWER, THEY
DON'T RESPECT THAT.
WHY WOULD YOU?
>> WE CAN AGREE FROM CERTAIN
LEVELS, WE CAN THINK EACH ONE IS
A DUMBASS.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S YOUR VIEW ON
FAUCI?
>> [BLEEP] FAUCI.
>> Tucker: DID YOU BELIEVE HIM
IN THE BEGINNING, FAUCI?
>> I BELIEVED IN ALL THE BULL
SHIP.
SHOOTING THIS DOCUMENTARY, SO
EMBARRASSED, EVERYBODY IS SPRING
OFF UPS PACKAGES.
AND LIKE...
WHAT?
IT'S KNOCKING OUT OLD,
OVERWEIGHT UNHEALTHY PEOPLE?
I'M GOOD.
MOST OF MY FRIENDS.
AFTER PEOPLE STARTED GETTING IT,
SOME PEOPLE HAVE A LITTLE WORSE
THAN OTHERS, BUT IT WAS NOTHING.
I DON'T WANT TO...
YOU KNOW, TO THROW ANY SHINE ON
PEOPLE WHO HAD A BAD TIME OR
PASSED AWAY WITH IT.
IT'S HORRIBLE.
WHEN ANYONE IS LOST.
TO ME, IT'S LIKE, THIS IS SOME
BULL LEAP IN ALL THIS MASK
[BLEEP], ALL THE DISINFORMATION
IT'S IN THE WORLD NOW AT EVERY
LEVEL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO BELIEVE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A MAN WHO
TALKS IN LIVES LIKE YOU MIGHT
TALK OR LIVE IF YOU ARE TOTALLY
INSULATED FROM BIG COMPANIES AND
COULD AFFORD IT.
IT WAS A FASCINATING EMPYREAN
EXPERIENCEWITH KID ROC